Statt 85 jahren einfach mal 150 jahre alt werden
Wer träumt davon nicht und wir berichten immer mal wieder darüber den gentechnik und medizin sind dabei
diesen alten menschheitstraum schon bald real werden
Zu lassen doch wie weit ist die forschung was bieten sich und dadurch für vorteile und würde unsere erde überhaupt mit all den nebenwirkungen
zurechtkommen herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction
Ja ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
Gewünscht wird damit dabei sein könnte und hiermit bestimmt was läuft das erfahrt ihr am ende
des videos das gilt übrigens auch mit anderen messengern ein ewiges leben
Das ist wohl der traum der meisten menschen eine pille gegen das altern oder gleich direkt
gegen den tod das wäre ja wohl was aber erfunden hat das noch niemand und vielen von uns
Reicht es nicht dass sich die lebenserwartung seit
1840 verdoppelt hat und sie alle vier jahre um ein weiteres jahr an steigt und so tüfteln
nicht nur medizin und gentechnik hartnäckig daran die lebensspanne von uns menschen
Um das zwei bis dreifache aus zu denen auch googles schwesterfirma kaliko beispielsweise geht gegen das alter vor
Eines der größten geheimnisse des lebens wie es auf der offiziellen website heißt menschen sollen durch die
fortschrittlichen technologien von kaliko schon bald gesünder und länger leben können
Was die forschungsteams hier genau machen was ist nicht so wirklich bekannt fest steht dass es
forschungsallianzen zu pharmaunternehmen gibt und man sich wohl auf
alterskrankheiten wie krebs diabetes
Demenz und herz kreislauf erkrankungen konzentriert und ähnlich wie mittlerweile, im gesamten silicon valley wird hier wohl die devise sein es gibt nichts was
datenverarbeitung und technologie nicht können und mit hilfe der daten sammele reihe von medizinischen und genetischen daten
könnte die lebensverlängerung tatsächlich eines tages wirklichkeit werden wir haben hier bei pixum sich schon mehrmals darüber berichtet beispielsweise auch über google
das mit hilfe einer software
depressionen heilen und herzinfarkte mit hilfe künstlicher nano-partikel
voraussagen will forschungsgruppen aus der biotechnik und medizin erhalten in naher zukunft eine verlängerung der menschlichen lebensspanne auf
150 jahre für realistisch
im besten fall eine zeit in der wir gesund leben können also in gewisser weise
vital sind dennoch ist auch hier ganz klar selbst wenn die wissenschaft in der lage ist und biologisch für eine längere zeit jung zu halten
gilt das nicht
gleichzeitig auch für unsere geistige jugend denn wie will man es verhindern dass unser geist erfahrung sammelt die welt kennen lernt und sich so
weiterentwickelt und in diesem sinne eben auch alter
philosophen diskutieren sogar darüber ob irgendwann der zeitpunkt gekommen ist an dem der menschliche geist soweit gealtert ist dass der dazugehörige
mensch gar nicht mehr unbedingt weiterleben möchte auf der anderen seite wäre
150 jahre langes leben natürlich eine große chance für den einzelnen menschen stellt euch mal vor man könnte in ruhe eine
ausbildung machen oder studieren dann 20 jahre lang beispielsweise als pilot durch die welt fliegen um dann nochmal ein
architekturstudium dranzuhängen zum schluss stünde dann noch eine karriere als
Sänger oder sängerin offen denn zeit um sich selbst zu verwirklichen wäre genug noch menschen die 150 jahre alt werden können
hätten fatale konsequenzen bezüglich der überbevölkerung und der sozialen ungerechtigkeit denn schon jetzt
Existieren zu viele menschen auf der erde und auch jetzt schon gibt es maßnahmen die das verhindern sollen china ist lange mit der sogenannten
ein-kind-politik gefahren solche maßnahmen müssten dann ja
Verschärft werden doch vorher steht eine wichtige debatte an was ist uns mehr wert die freiheit für jeden einzelnen von uns sich
Sofort zu pflanzen wer möchte oder aber die möglichkeit seine eigene lebensspanne
signifikant auszuweiten ihr seht also das ganze macht dringend auch ethische
Diskussionen notwendig und da ist dann auch eine philosophische frage, zu stellen nur weil es demnächst
wissenschaftlich und medizinisch
Möglich sein wird 150 jahre alt zu werden
sollen wir menschen das eigentlich voll
Denn sicher ist teure therapien um das leben
zu verlängern könnten sich zumindest anfangs nur reiche leute leisten diejenigen also die auch schon in vielen anderen bereichen des lebens
privilegiert sind und sie hätten ganz andere interessen als menschen mit einer kurzen lebensspanne das würde wiederum eine zweiklassengesellschaft
verschärfen bevor also solche medizinischen möglichkeiten zur verfügung stehen muss schon
Im voraus blickt vieles beachtet und diskutiert werden wenn er als erstes neues zum thema
Uralt werden und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp
Wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr euch auch mit mir über telegramm instagram oder den facebook messenger
verknüpfen dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich
andy kann dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von links und mitmachen und mitbestimmen
Was hier praktisch schon passiert der direkte draht zu mir und zu beginn gibt es auch noch ein kleines goodie
einfach hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken ist der tod tödlich oder leben wir weiter ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran